Apple TV plus dropped their new
television series today called The Silo
but should you give it a go welcome to
sidetracking your Sci-Fi TV a movie
channel
[Music]
so it's fair to say I am not a massive
fan of sort of post-apocalyptic High
concept sci-fi even some of the more
popular stuff like say Blade Runner I
think it's clever I can appreciate the
thought that goes into it and I can
really appreciate the art but I don't
find them particularly interesting I
find them a little boring
now this new TV series The Silo dropping
on Apple Plus today with this first
three episodes is 100 a high concept
post-apocalyptic story
but
it's way way more than that and I'm
going to tell you with a few little
spoilers to be prepared all about the
first episode and ask the question
should you watch it
so first of all a little bit of the
background so this was actually based on
the wall series by Hugh Howey it was
first bought for the television rights
in 20 by 20th Century Fox in 2012 Ridley
Scott and Steve's alien were going to
run it that didn't happen after Disney
bought 20th Century Fox and it sort of
fizzled out 2018 though AMC got hold of
the rights and Latoya Morgan was going
to develop but that kind of fizzled out
too Apple got hold of the rights and
Graham Yost was brought under to right
so first of all
straight off the bat my first instinct
is
they've appalled this what we expect
from Apple are big stars big names act
as you know
yeah all the way through this there's
some brilliant actors
um Rebecca Ferguson is probably going to
be the lead actress she is great in most
things I've seen her in obviously we
know her best from the Mission
Impossible movies David oylo it's just a
name I can't quite say plays the sheriff
he's again a British actor that I know
from lots of things over in the UK
appears a lot of BBC dramas is a
phenomenally good actor and Rashida
Jones who plays Alison his wife is also
just amazing in this she has a really
really difficult part
um spoiler she is trying to have a baby
in this and they fail and basically the
way she reacts to that and deals with it
it does pull on the heartstrings so what
is actually going on in this series in
this first episode well as I said they
start asking questions immediately in
the first few seconds you wonder what is
the sheriff doing with the air vent what
is he doing with the flowers what's the
note what's the just everything and then
it flashes back three years
we then see the sheriff with his wife
Alison and they're trying to have a baby
now in this again it's a very very
controlled Society they live in within
the silo this bunker that they're
protected from the outside world with
the outside world being poisonous and
even in spacesuits you die almost
instantly if you go outside
so to have a baby you have to actually
um apply and then you get um as part of
a lottery by look you get picked to even
have the chance of having a baby you
then basically get 12 months to see if
you can get pregnant if you don't you
don't
um for the rest of the time you have a
contraceptive device inserted inside you
that's not very nice now all the way
through this first episode the concept
of freedom is explored in a couple of
different ways and the illusion of
Freedom now in this case they see that
they are being allowed to have a baby
and that is purely by look it's a
lottery but is that actually the way it
is or are certain people selected to be
allowed to have kids and others not in
this case the lottery and this freedom
to then at least try is a complete
illusion and at no point was actually
Alison going to be allowed to have a
baby because she's not the right sort of
person she's too free thinking there
actually trying to breed out that and
they're trying to breed out any future
Rebellion so we find out as well that
actually the number one rule within the
silo is that you do not ask to go
outside if you do ask to go outside and
anyone hears you say it you get to go
and that's basically a death sentence if
you get caught trying to dig into the
past of The Silo that was wiped out in a
rebellion 140 years before this was set
then also you get to go outside it's
basically the biggest punishment for any
criminal you get to go outside and clean
the senses that project images of the
outside world to everybody else within
the silo a pretty horrible image of the
outside world by the way all the way
through as well it is hinted that there
is a
government Above The Silo some of this
Judiciary this potentially this pact
um and we don't really get to see I
don't think who is actually in charge of
this the brilliant actor Tim Robbins has
a very very small part in the very first
episode I suspect we're going to see him
a lot more in later episodes I think he
is to do with actually who's in charge
of this and not the main sort of leader
that we get to see the main leader we
get to see is very upset when the Alison
character actually is forced to go
outside and then die you can't fake that
she is beside herself with remorse and
guilt so again there's that illusion of
Freedom you can ask to go outside if you
want to but if you ask to go outside
you'll be allowed to and you'll die
so again illusion of freedom
so is this High concept is this a
post-apocalyptic story yes it is of
course it is but it's also a murder
mystery it's a political intrigue
mystery and it's very high intense drama
it's got an excellent budget and an
excellent cast so should you watch it if
you've got Apple TV 100 you're already
going to be watching it they've
advertising this like crazy haven't they
it's literally everywhere it's all over
IMDb it's all over us because it's even
been advertised on the cinemas Etc here
in the UK if you've got Apple TV 100 you
should watch it and I'm certain you will
enjoy it if you haven't got Apple TV
should you think about getting it for
this series
to be honest it is that good I would
suggest any big sci-fi fan would enjoy
this the things that I like about it us
it's going to be big mystery but it's
based on a novel Series so thinking
about series like lost they set up all
this mystery we all wondered what the
hell is going on but they obviously
didn't really have a plan because then
it sort of wandered and was a victim of
its own success and in the end you just
think what was that all about
well with this series I think there will
be a conclusion there will be something
that makes sense because there's a plan
because the books have already been
written so for one
that's a bonus for two apple have really
spent the money it is a very visually
pretty series and um you won't be
disappointed from that point of view the
actors are excellent you won't be
disappointed from that point of view so
really that's a perfect storm it's the
trifecta my advice if you have an Apple
TV but you can get sort of a free trial
wait for this series to finish
get the free trial binge you it's worth
it should you pay to get Apple TV to get
it
if you want to watch Ted lasso and films
like ghosted which is actually on a
moment Chris Evans is in it he's also
great it's a very good film actually
then yeah get it pay for it for a month
binge all these things and then maybe
get rid of it to be honest if I'm 100
honest about Apple TV there's not enough
content on there to pay for it and keep
it
get it for a month
cancel it as soon as you're done binge
Ted lasso binge a couple of the movies
that are on there that are really good
there's a series called shrink down
there at the moment so it's actually
pretty good um Harrison Ford's in it
with a few others binge of stuff that's
on there but then get rid of it get it
again in 12 months time sort of thing
it's there's just not enough on there to
actually Warren
um the keeping it sort of long term that
just isn't so against the comments guys
tell me what you think if you've got
Apple TV have you seen the first couple
of episodes of this what do you think do
you agree with me is it worth a go or
actually are you not getting Apple TV
for this sort of show you're just gonna
maybe hope this is released on DVD which
it might be and in that case give it a
go then it's worth it
against the comps and tell me exactly
what you're thinking if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where you get to
see most of our videos first and for a
small contribution each month you get to
see them without the adverts as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
foreign